what is it that you think led to Sony
deciding to come forward and release
this not only online but in roughly 300
theaters I think Sony's kind of reacting
to a swing and public opinion if you
will I think initially when the news
first broke about the hacking and I
think they took a very cautious approach
and just decided to step back pull the
movie back from all distribution all
release but in the several days since
they made that announcement I think a
lot of public opinion has swung or
decide and sort of side of free speech
and that Sony someway somehow should get
this movie out into the marketplace of
course President Obama weighed in as
well
so I think that all wait upon Sony and
since then over the last couple of days
I think they've been talking with all
their partners both at the theatrical
level and also on the online
distributional level to see is there any
way that we can get this movie out as
quickly as we can to as many towards
widen audiences that we can in a you
know I think a responsible way yeah you
know Jordan we saw from the hackers that
they're starting some kind of 9/11 style
attacks how vulnerable does that we've
Sony and the theaters that are
distributing this I think a lot of
people you know took a look at that
threat and certainly the the homeland
security department also took a look at
it and said that there was no credible
evidence of a physical attack imminent
so you know a lot of people took from
that some comfort that we can go to the
movie theaters these are computer
hackers most likely not physical
attackers you know but certainly
releasing the movie online there's a
business calculation as well is that
Sony's trying to recruit any money of
the 80 million dollars it spent making
and promoting this movie and they'll
only get a fraction of that online and
through the 300 theaters where they're
distributing this movie it was
originally intended to open in three
thousand so somebody's gonna take a big
loss on this one but at least it's
getting out and you know there was a lot
of public pressure on them to do this
you know let me let me just share with
you some news that we're getting it is
being reported that the interview the
movie is going to be available today at
1:00 p.m. on
- for rent Cory Johnson are there gonna
be people out there that might be
reluctant to download this movie because
they're concerned about potential hacked
hackers and and malware creeping into
their own computers I mean who knows
what the the individual reactions will
be it's really interesting to watch Sony
try to navigate this from a business
perspective there's tremendous change of
course going on in the movie industry
the least of which is the shrinking of
time from when a movie is released in
the theater to when it's released online
and released for home video that was a
hundred and seventy days five years ago
sound 100 and I think three days in the
last in the third quarter now it's
apparently going to be on the same day
with this release Sony has its own
online video service with a little-known
crackle which is trying to compete with
Netflix and delight and so that's one of
the services one might expect Sony to
release this online but if they're
trying to get theaters to run this now
in this reversal of course and at the
same time putting it online undercutting
the theatrical business it raises lots
of issues about their relationship with
the theaters the relationship between
the individual theaters the support they
have for their own business of crackle
and partnerships they might have with
other outlets like Google or like
Netflix it also raises a big question of
what kind of insurance settlement they
might get they're reportedly we're
looking at a seventy five million dollar
loss on this release so what does that
mean for this insurance settlement if
this movie does get out there and what
kind of profit might they ultimately
make like no one the other movie has a
lot of questions that I surprised her
that Sony did this about-face Jordan I
mean to say you know look we're not
gonna release it and then suddenly to
say okay here it is once the president
you mentioned it in his press conference
and publicly shamed Sony for not
releasing it it was really inevitable at
this point that they would release it
you know bokura is an interesting point
about the insurance that that is a it's
a very significant factor in all of this
because if Sony was not able to release
the movie it could potentially write off
all of its costs and expenses for making
and promoting it but now that it's
releasing it you know it can't it can no
longer go back to the insurer and say
the whole thing is a loss Wow they're
gonna take a hit on it and that's
wait Paul we're hearing somewhere around
200 million I think you're all in Kostas
you know the direct cost is 100 million
dollars but that's the bigger issue I
think persona has always been
reputational the reputational risk with
the creative community in Hollywood with
the directors and the writers and the
producers will they stand behind a movie
and then also with their their theater
distributors as well so right they have
a lot of relationship building good to
do Corinne I think he makes a really
good point if I'm a film creator
director writer in Hollywood right now I
might not want to work with Sony on my
next project because there's this fear
that you know if I do anything that's
politically incorrect I may have the
North Koreans coming down on me well I
mean forget Kim jong-un they've ticked
off George Clooney I mean you know in
Hollywood it is a lot about the
relationships and now you know they've
added in the last hour added in this
complication with their relationship
with the theater owners themselves and
those important couple of chains as well
as the independent theater owners if
they're gonna be putting this thing out
there online or even announcing the
possibility of it being online just as
people could be lining up to buy tickets
to buy this thing on Christmas to make a
statement
Sony has has really mismanaged this over
and over again throughout this this
problem that has cropped up in their
business yeah well I mean who knows I
mean on some level I think a lot of
people were thinking that it was unfair
that their personal emails were hacked
and that they were kind of being
embarrassed here but they really have
bungled this in many counts and we may
be seeing more of that in real time
right now